In the developer console,
when you create a billing account,
there are a number of steps
that you need to go through.
The first is to name the account.
And then later on when you're
creating your project,
you'll pick the billing
account based on its name.
Then you have to specify the country for
the account and
where the account resides.
Payer details are going to
be linked to this country.
So be sure to pick the right one.
Then you just pick the account type.
You might be paying as a business or
you might be paying as an individual.
You just pick which one.
Next comes the payer details.
And that's just the name and
address of the payer.
And then finally there's
the payment type.
And this is going to be a credit card or
bank details.
And depending on which one you pick,
you have to configure it.
It's as simple as that.
Once you've filled out this form with
all of these details and submit it,
it will take a few moments.
But then billing will be available and
you'll be able to create a project and
select the billing profile
that you've just set up.